and now here is an actor i haven't shown
you a hollywood a good old-fashioned
hollywood actor in a while well here is
robert de niro okay
robert de niro went on the stephen
colbert program i don't think anyone's
watching it actually uh my buddy greg
gutfeld he has the number one show on
late night television right now it's
crushing cold air even though colbert
probably has 100 people that work for
him and gutfeld literally has i think
four people that work on his show it's
awesome uh but de niro went on colbert
to defend joe biden because he's an
actor and actors act and they act and
they make up scripts and they hopefully
try to pass it as truth but i think
you're gonna see right through it like i
know that you you you have a fair amount
of uh you have emotions about politics
you have thoughts of course first those
stir emotions i know you have some
anxiety about state of politics in the
united states having a new guy at 1600
pennsylvania avenue has that have you
sleep any better at night yes
he's uh you know he he got us into calm
waters that was always the idea yeah
he's doing a very good job it's a tough
one i couldn't imagine i i could imagine
how difficult it is
um
i have decisions in my own personal life
that i imagine that what he goes through
is a hundred times that yeah and and so
uh no he's doing the best he can and and
uh
we got to get through a bad period
period yeah
well joe's doing the best he can but you
know the audience applause he's got
biden now it's all very exciting uh
let's not forget
de niro he is quite a political
analysis okay this is a guy who knows
what he's doing he thinks through the
issues he makes calm and reasoned
arguments why he likes joe biden you
just heard it there you know it's tough
it's just doing fine uh and you may
remember this one this was one of we had
to go through there's a whole bunch of
them this is one of his best i thought
this the way he sort of really captures
everything about donald trump right here
[Music]
i'm going to say one thing [ __ ] trump
[Applause]
you get it i think you get it
you